[Music]
all they are showing
all day today i don't care if you're
watching the news i don't care if you're
watching a daytime talk show
every every show all they're doing is
airing footage of the president and the
first lady at the inaugural ball and i
have to say on a personal level i felt
kind of
kind of bad for them because i thought
it must be hard to do something so
intimate
as to slow dance in front of the whole
world you know they're they're man
they're slow dancing you know what i
mean there's no way i could do it i mean
it just it it's too creepy in a way you
know yeah yeah it just feels to me like
it's such an intimate moment uh between
a couple and i just felt like an
invasion of privacy to me you know yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
i wouldn't be surprised
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
all is i'm the lady i don't care we got
a great trophy tonight from the eight
time oscar named film silver lighting's
playbook and the upcoming abc movie the
makeover julia styles
from the new fx series legit dj qualls
[Applause]
musical guest the lone bellow
[Applause]
all right
[Applause]